I'd like you to follow along with me
okay but what I'm gonna do is the
workings all there I'm not asking you to
do the working but I'm asking you to
analyze what's going on
okay one of the operations that are
taking place from line to line right
so for instance the first thing I'd like
you to do is this is actually pretty
much the first I think actually do four
lines or something like that the first
four lines are working okay so this
looks pretty similar so what I what you
do is have a look at line one to line 2
by 1 that's just converting the system I
gave you right and now it's in matrix
form so far so good
what has changed from line 1 to line 2
have a thing which line is which row I
should say which row is being adjusted
the third right right okay what have we
done into the third room hmm
look carefully look carefully I think
I've taken Row 3 and what I done good ok
now I'm going to up and they sort of
like you to have along with your work
right I'm going to write that in a
particular way watch this is the way
I've written ok
why got that there I don't know what ok
now even though we're used to addition
as an operation that you can change the
order 1 plus 3 3 plus 1 same thing right
oh by the way that has a name no that's
called that quality sake let's see you
learnt it in year 7 is that they on yeah
I think I've heard it it's that addition
is commutative in that you can you guys
know what commuting is like when people
say I'm commuting to work it means
you're you're moving from one place to
another
right so addition just like
multiplication you can flip these around
I'm going to not do it like that I'm
going to suggest that this Row 3 plus
Row 2 is actually a little bit different
to Row 2 plus Row 3 can you see what I
mean right right to you I haven't
changed
this son whoops you've gotta watch out
for the cable this row - in this row -
identical
yeah but this row three it's changed
what have I done to it I've added row -
is everyone okay so far yeah okay this
is gonna be important as we keep going
so now I have a look at the next room
and I'm gonna tell you right now I don't
always just do one operation I usually
do just to make things simpler but
sometimes I'll do more than one what has
changed from this line to the next first
row has it changed
Roach's changed how has row to change
okay so let's have a look all right
let's see yeah right
haha there we go not too bad right do
you see what's happened why did I do
this by the way I put up the top here
then I'm calling this method and
arbitrate or die I'm just kind of doing
it sorta randomly but I'm actually
working towards something why why did I
do that what I do that not something
else
haha two plus one is three sighs in
that's that's what how you can do it
okay good that's very true why would we
do that though like why is that a useful
that's gonna help me get to this
solution why is that handy hmm let me
rewind let me rewind why did I add these
two rows why is that a common sense of
direction to go in
yeah very good okay we have language for
this don't we when you're solving
simultaneous equations this K was gonna
be problematic for me when you saw us on
the state equation equations you're
trying to eliminate one of the
pronumerals from a pair of the equations
right if I can get two less of them like
rather than three if I just have to I
can solve those right so that's why I
did this so I did this adding that makes
a zero there now can you see why I did
this right because now I have the same
zeros here in kyo does that make sense
so this is an equation in s and B's and
C's to begin with right so now if you
have a look at this line that we're up
to look at Row two and Row three here
can you see that if you rewrote them as
equations what would they look like
no seriously what would they look like a
plus B plus C equals zero okay so far so
good I didn't really touch that road did
I write 2 that would be 3 a + 4 C equals
4 right that's pretty wonky I should
look at what I'm writing
what's the bus right - a + just a say
equals 6 ah look see look if they see
how this is better this is an
improvement right now I don't have to
worry about B I've eliminated and now I
can solve that just like you would
normally in like write or whenever it
was that you
kind of handle this okay keep going
let's have a look the next one what's
changed which row am I looking at this
is an easier one
it's the third row how have I adjusted
it yeah good i multiplied why tell me
why why did I multiply yeah good so just
like here right you'd say I want these
to cancel now can you see why that's a
better choice than say mucking around
with the A's why is it make more sense
to do with the seat very good if I
wanted to do that a xylophone this by 2
and this by 3 and then I'd get 6a right
but here I only have to adjust one row
row three and then I'm good these guys
can cancel now you can see where it's
gonna go what happens in the next slide
what operation there's there's
subtraction right what subtracts from
one
yeah good read three - right - you can
see it okay by the way remember how I
said to you before
yes matrices have some disadvantages but
they also have some advantages versus
some taste equations as I go through
this can you see I don't have to talk
about equation one and then two and then
three and then four and five and six and
seven I don't have to keep track of them
I can just say well Row 3 is Row 3 and
Row 2 is Row 2 and they're just that's
fine okay have a look what have I done
here now this is trickier right because
you can see two rows have changed right
and they have changed in a particular
order which were do you think I would
have changed first which makes the most
sense Row 3 makes the most sense right
because what do you have to do to it all
you have to do is divine okay now keep
that in your mind you divided it so that
turned the five to one
the twenty into a four and then what did
I do to the other room there's a
subtraction right you look at Row two
and you're like I've got I've got that
3a up the front and I don't want it to
be there so how do I get rid of it I
subtract what I subtracted is 3 times
Row three see it okay and you see the
order matters by the way you've got to
do the division first otherwise you've
got five of them and that's not useful
to you okay all right now have a look
again at these last two bits here right
there almost there aren't there one zero
zero four that tells you the original
question is equal to four that's all it
is right row two that tells you original
question four C equals negative eight
right so now you can tell me what I did
in this line
yeah I just divided that out there you
go
all right and then final line final line
I only had to do one thing really right
what did I do
yeah I've got I've got 1 1 1 and I only
want to have that one left right so I
take away both of these both of them ok
you got to be careful because there's
negatives and subtract my kind of thing
but hey go that's all you have to do and
then you've got all the ones and all the
zeroes and it's happy it makes sense you
all right with that
ok great